any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
some upbeat music to start what will
undoubtedly be an upbeat episode of the
into the impossible podcast with my
friend
my youtube mentor
uh dr sabina hossenfelder joining us all
the way from germany sabina how are you
doing today doctor
i'm great
good to see you brian
it's good to see you i see you every
saturday night here i don't watch uh you
know internet on on the sabbath which
we'll get into but uh
there's so much that's been going on
since you made your last appearance and
i can't tell
if you are
getting more optimistic about physics
more pessimistic about physics or more
of the same what do you think about
philosophy and is it dangerous for
physicists to
engage in it
well
uh depends on what you mean with
dangerous um so
is it is it dangerous career-wise
probably yes
because as you say a lot of physicists
are quite skeptical that it's worth the
time
so if you spend a lot of your time on
philosophy
they would consider it a waste of time
and
that's not good if you want to get ahead
in your job
but personally i would say
every good scientist
not necessarily physicists but
scientists in general
needs a solid philosophical background
just to understand how science works in
the first place
so i i really think you can't do without
um
and if if you don't have those spaces it
comes back to haunt you uh because
you'll you'll be confusing what you
actually know with what you just believe
what do you make about
the upsurge or the propensity that
physicists have for hype
compared to the other sciences do you
think
physicists hype uh potential
results or you know newfound discoveries
more than in other fields uh for example
like biology or chemistry
well i think it it really depends very
strongly on the field so if you're
looking at the foundations of physics i
dare to say the answer is probably yes
especially if you compare it with
fields like public health
medicine in general
cancer research that kind of thing and i
suspect that part of the reason is
that it doesn't really matter you know i
mean you get something wrong when it
comes to health people may die right so
so everyone's like super super careful i
mean at least they should be super
careful
okay uh but i mean you you say something
wild about
the multiverse um or i don't know some
particle that no one will ever see
anyway what does it matter right so i
kind of feel that physicists you know
take a lot of freedom uh because they
figure it doesn't hurt anyone and it
helps their own career and
one apology that i've also heard is that
people just think well it's inspiring
and it
might young people to get into science
and that kind of stuff
right
and of course the biggest scale things
that we talk about
is uh is nothing less than the size of
the universe on its biggest scales and
then of course the smallest elements of
nature elementary particles and and
maybe what happened at the at the
boundaries of the origin of time the
origin of space if such a thing took
place i wanted to ask you i recently saw
a paper uh that you put out a couple of
weeks ago about uh averaging processes
and general relativity and i want to get
into that uh before i do i wanted to um
to talk about you know what we've
learned in the last few years both since
lost in math was published three years
ago and uh and and where that knowledge
is coming from i i see a lot of you know
references to new experiments and and
and discoveries even in your paper you
mentioned virgo and ligo and and
implicit observations from gravitational
waves from black holes etcetera
and yet
it doesn't stop people from kind of
maybe being overly optimistic about what
future experiments could do for example
i've heard a lot of talk recently about
lisa a gravitational wave observatory in
space that could do
for cosmology what ligo has done for
astrophysics what do you make of such
claims uh that you could perhaps detect
you know primordial uh tensor
perturbations that you could detect
these averaging processes that we're
going to talk about in your paper or the
effects of these of of of perhaps
observables related to your recent paper
do you think that this is another
example of you know people kind of
overestimating the power in this case of
experiment not math
so the thing with the gravitational
waves is we kind of know they have to be
there and we've already seen them in a
particular wavelength range
and so what the new experiments can do
is that they would be looking at uh
larger distances that's why you want to
put them into space because it makes it
easier to use lasers over long distance
without
getting
a headache from the noise and so on and
so forth and
it makes sense to me i mean
of course no one
knows for certain
how large the amplitude is in which
wavelength
regime you can only estimate it and
that's exactly the same thing that they
have done for the solar mass black holes
which were now seeing the gravitational
waves of and of course they were off
with the estimate for a long time
which is why all the other the earlier
experiments didn't see anything and you
know at some point i thought everyone
was like oh my god we'll never see it
right because you get all these null
results but eventually they did see it
and uh why is that well well because
gravitational waves
were
a great prediction right coming out of a
very well
confirmed theory
general relativity
and
it it would have been
inconsistent if we had not seen the
medicine
at some point
and um
it's certainly true that if we see these
uh gravitational waves from from
supermassive black holes or from the
early universe
that would teach us something really new
about the cosmos
right because there's always the notion
bigger is better in experiments too and
i'm as guilty of that as anybody with my
cosmic microwave background experiments
now
participating in the largest most
ambitious one ever funded
although there is one on the horizon
called cmb stage four which is even
bigger more expensive but that's in the
proposal phase still we'll see what the
decadal survey comes out with but i
wonder you know um a general question
i've always wanted to ask you when we
look at something like cosmology and in
your recent paper you you talk about
these memory effects and and so forth
but you start with the standard model of
cosmology um but it's it sort of strikes
me as unusual in that
cosmology it we don't really have a good
solid sense of the initial conditions of
the physical system we have boundary
conditions but in physics as i
understood it we always need to have
initial conditions how is it possible to
to um you know do the types of analyses
that you do in this recent paper of
averaging of course graining
and then highly non-linear system of gr
when we don't even know
how the initial conditions led to the
friedman robertson lemaitre walker
universe how is it okay to do such a
thing
well
it's a model right so the way i look at
it is you make certain assumptions uh
then you derive the consequences and
then you look at what the data says does
it work or does it not work um i mean
you you can always ask this question
about the initial conditions where do
they actually come from uh how do we
know uh and it creates this chicken and
egg problem right because there's always
an earlier state that gave rise to your
initial condition where did that come
from well it came from an even earlier
state right
so eventually
we just treat it as an assumption that
goes into the model
and i mean in this paper which is a
fairly short paper that's making a teeny
tiny contribution to a huge problem what
i think is a huge problem
um
we uh just use the simplest example just
to show it's possible to do it and
hopefully also
to
stimulate some other people to look at
it
because the math gets complicated very
very quickly general relativity the
theory that we currently use for
cosmology
is a non-linear theory so that's the
kind of theory that has chaos and all
kinds of difficult things
and what happens in this kind of theory
is
that you can't just average over the
equations
um
it's
it in general very very difficult to
average over nonlinear equations and um
this is something which people do all
the time if they use climate models for
example and also in condensed
metaphysics uh where the equations are
non-linear
and um
this this always made me think like why
aren't we doing the same thing in
general relativity and so there's
there's a long story in the literature
where people have argued we don't need
to do it because the corrections would
be teeny tiny tiny and it doesn't really
matter um and then there's some other
people who have said well actually those
arguments don't really work and then
there are some other people who have
said well actually they do work and and
so this is concerned back and forth
between theoreticians arguing
uh but there are very few mathematical
techniques by which you can actually
calculate it and so what we did in the
paper was uh to say well let's take uh
one of those techniques um that people
use in condensed metaphysics and just
try to apply it uh to cosmology as a
whole and that way you can actually
calculate some correction terms
and unfortunately we have not been able
to um calculate how large they are but
we were able to calculate um their
functional dependence on the hubble rate
yes and you address the hubble tension
as a you know potential um
participant in in some of this i want to
ask you um about about these kinds of
papers and you know a critic of yours
and i i understand there's a couple of
people that criticize you sabina uh but
but not me uh but you know critic might
say well what are the testable
predictions of of this new you know
course granting and even you and i have
both engaged in in you know discussions
of what counts as science and
falsifiability is popper the final word
is he like girdle no um but i want to
ask you to do a thought experiment so
imagine you and i go back to 1864.
there's a young scottish mathematician
named james clerk maxwell
and he comes up with these four
equations that will later bear his name
and in so doing he comes up with a
physical model for how these equations
support the propagation of
electromagnetic radiation and it
involves this wonderful thing called the
gear and a whirlpool and a and a vortex
and all this nonsense and he goes on
twitter uh because let's say in this
example twitter exists
160 years ago and he tweets about it
i've got this great idea would we not
have said look not only is your theory
crazy it's already demonstrably wrong
you know that we don't you know we use
these microscopes we don't see any gears
or what what have you uh and uh is there
such a thing as requiring falsifiability
too early in your opinion is that a
mistake
i wouldn't call it a mistake
but
it's certainly not conductive
to the full development of an idea
right i mean though i'm not entirely
sure that i
understand this example correctly
because maxwell after all did predict
something that was also falsifiable and
then you could have said did you
actually need all these gears or
wouldn't have been wouldn't it it'd have
been sufficient to just start with the
fields which is exactly what we do now
um so so i'm not sure that maxwell is
the best example in this case um but uh
in in general there's certainly a risk
that you um
prevent
a promising idea from ever being fully
developed uh just by yelling it's not
fortifiable uh because no one's figured
out how it falls fired
right and i see this even with things
like the hubble tension
and uh and even things as diverse as
aliens you know we we we have in the us
this recent report released by the
pentagon uh you know which is like our
military uh headquarters and it's kind
of ambiguous and a lot could be read
into it i wonder if you've been
following this i know you did a video
about
you know credibility and believability
and bayesian inference in low signal
high noise environments
can you say something about this as
applies to things like um
the problem of aliens existing which
which has a lot of attention both both
uh in the u.s and in europe what do you
make of such things why why is it
happening now
um well why is it happening now i don't
think that it just only started
happening now like
this has been around for a long time
right people have always yelled i mean
not always but for the past 50 years or
something and there have been lots of
reports of uh you know unidentified
flying objects and that kind of stuff
and every once in a while he bubbles up
and then he calms down
and so that there are just unexplained
things uh in nature um and i think there
will always be and of course it's
perfectly justified to ask like what is
it can we look at it closer um we want
to know what it is
uh right so uh i i think that that's
perfectly fine i mean that's uh how i
how i want society to be right there's
something we don't understand that's uh
let's look at it
that's that's perfectly fine
where i get a problem is when people
jump to conclusions that are not really
supported by the data
in regards to ufos and with data
astronomers as my friend sarah skulls
who wrote a book about alien sightings
and so forth
and pointed out you know astronomers
have a vested interest in discovering
aliens and spacecraft and and so forth
uh in part it was instant tenure right
probably a nobel prize although you know
how i feel about that and uh and then
secondly you know we could shortcut 20
centuries of of learning about physics
perhaps so we have the most incentive to
discover it you think there'd be a
confirmation bias plus
we have all the tools we spend every
night looking at the skies with high
cadence and frequencies from megahertz
to you know to uh well into the uh to
the gamma ray so every night we're
studying it and yet we've never had a
credible peer-reviewed you know uh paper
published about it from the astronomical
community and so when people ask for
data i just i guess i wonder what are
you looking for i mean
data that confirms that they exist uh
because i i mean i don't know if you
agree with this sabine but um the hubble
deep field you've seen the image correct
so
that's that's data i suppose but it's
really just a pretty picture to get the
data you need the calibration you need
the flat fielding you need the dark
current you need you need all the stuff
that went into making the image and even
the image you know only allows you to
maybe do a count or maybe some rough
histograms but what do you what do you
mean by data like for people to see data
what would count as data even in
something as as abnormal or maybe
one-off as a ufo or alien encounter
so
given the
huge potential payoff it's certainly
something that we should invest in and i
would go so far to say that we're not
investing
enough into it so i i don't have a big
problem with people who want to see more
alien searches
um to put it this way
but i but i also think that um what what
a lot of people really have a problem
with is to say
we just don't know right we have this
video or we have this data
uh or we have
whatever else you know a blip in a curve
something like this we don't actually
know what it is they they have this urge
that they must find an explanation which
sometimes just isn't possible and and so
you end up with
more guesswork than science
right
one other area that always reminds me of
this is when we talk about the
multiverse and and i know you've written
about this as a form of religion i
wonder if just for my audience that's
not familiar with your with your comment
on it could you uh recapitulate or state
what you've uh written in the past about
the multiverse sort of as a form of of
religious dogma even though you yourself
are obviously uh declared
secular and not practicing religion
right
yeah right so what i've been trying to
get across is that if you assume
that something
exists which you can't observe
um
that's not a scientific type of
existence
and that doesn't mean it's wrong
but it means it's not the subject of
science
you can of course believe in it so um
you know if someone wants to believe
there are infinitely many copies of them
out there in a multiverse living life in
all kinds of way that you can think of
i don't think there's anything wrong
with it um i i get a problem when people
say that this is science like science
told me uh there's this multiverse uh
science told me there are infinitely
many other universes
um because it's just not correct and and
that brings us back by the way to what
you asked in the beginning like why does
philosophy matter
and that's one of the reasons why it
matters because
scientists who argue this way
they
assign reality
to
some mathematical structures
that pop up in the equations and the
question is like how's this justified to
which my answer is well it just isn't
right um
so
i mean if you if you're speaking of the
scientific kind of existence like we've
proved
it must exist that kind of thing you
just can't do it if you can't observe it
and so what about things that are in
principle i agree with you but what
about things that are in principle
unobservable like a singularity in a
black hole
no one actually believes that that's
what really what's really inside a black
hole um
but maybe more importantly uh no one
i mean no one maybe uh there are some
people probably who believe it but uh
i've worked on black hole physics for
like 10 years or something and i would
say pretty much no one in the community
thinks that black holes are really
eternal so the black hole horizon just
doesn't just stay there forever uh but
the black hole evaporates uh this is
what hawking predicted and so it the
black hole shrinks and at some point
it's so small that and this brings us
back to the problem uh the horizon
uh has shrunken into the quantum
gravitational regime and so we don't
really know what happens
uh
but uh presumably the horizon
disappears and so this region inside the
black hole does not remain disconnected
from the universe
forever and this is kind of what hawking
meant when he said um
black holes don't exist
but what he really meant is that these
eternal black holes
that we see in general relativity don't
exist
because in in the end
they are gone
now you can ask of course do we actually
know this
to which the answer is no we don't uh
because we've never seen a black hole
evaporating so it's it's
pure speculation
um but i think that given that the
theory actually tells you you should be
able to observe it
in principle
um it's
it's not completely disconnected from
the word it's
scientifically um
well-funded i would say to talk about
what's inside a black hole
so if it if that wasn't the case you
know if it was really um completely
disconnected and we could never observe
anything inside it i would say exactly
the same about the inside of black holes
and then
i say about the multiverse uh i would
say well we can never observe it
um
so why talk about it i mean that's the
the other thing is of course that in
principle if you cross the black hole
horizon you can very well observe what's
inside the black or you just
can't come back and tell us about it
so sabine i wonder if you've had a
chance to read this wonderful new book
called the god equation by michio kaku
no i haven't read it but i've heard of
it
so at the end of it he concludes with
the exact same words uh of stephen
hawking which we were just talking about
in the context of black hole evaporation
he concludes when we get string theory
we'll have a theory of everything and we
will know the mind of god and uh first
of all i think there are a lot of you
know people that use the word god a
little bit too cavalierly not not for
religious reasons just because i don't
think they really know anything about
god or like western philosophy and and
or eastern mysticism at all but anyway
leave that aside mitchie is a good
character but the thing that really
troubled me about his statement
was that uh i asked him i said michio
you know recently we had g minus two
results we had the lhc uh beauty
experiment results we have hubble
tension we have all these things never
once did i hear a string theorist tell
me look out for this particular
deviation of the muon's magnetic moment
because it's right here in string theory
so that's number one number two i had
cameron vapha on my show and i said you
know come on come on uh what you know
what does string theory ever predict it
and he said no no you're wrong so there
are many things about string theory that
can be predicted we have many
encouraging results the work of
beckenstein hawking which you just
mentioned sabine
they make a prediction and here's the
prediction these predictions are for
example if you take the electron it has
a mass and if you compute the mass of
the electron in the fundamental units of
physics which is the planck mass it's a
very tiny mass something of order 10 to
the minus 23. a very tiny number do we
have any prediction that the electron
mass should have this in mind without
knowing there
without knowing there is an electron
just knowing there is electric charge
and by knowing there's dark energy in
the universe you find a bound on the
electron mass from string theory you
find a bound that the electron mass
should be bounded by 10 to the minus 1
planck mass
on the upper end and above 10 to the
minus 31 on the lower edge first of all
what do you make of this uh this this i
mean if i made a prediction you know
that was
had an error bar of 10 to the 30th
magnitude uh i would be uh i would be a
little bit
embarrassed but technically he's right
it did make it could have been 10 to the
minus 32 but it wasn't anyway it's been
what do you make of these uh claims that
it's incumbent upon other physicists
to establish boundary conditions and
initial conditions uh and then once you
do shrink theory has everything in it
including g minus two and uh and fifth
forces etc
yeah um
maybe um he means something else by
prediction than what most people mean
but for most people i think that you
predict something before it's measured
okay so
um i would say what he's shown is that
at least the theory is compatible with
observations if you look at that
particular feature i mean
let's decide the issue that
it has some
dimensions too much and some moduli too
much and um
other problems uh like all those super
symmetric particles which we haven't
seen and and all that kind of stuff
and uh
so
look a lot of people think that
that i'm a string theory hater um but
definitely isn't so um i think string
theory had a very good motivation um
you know people were
trying to
unify
gravity with quantum theory that's the
the exact problem that we just talked
about um with
uh sorry the singularity in black holes
and and all that kind of stuff and
strictly really looked like it could get
the job done
because it has those graviton
excitations
but it didn't really pan out
right they never actually proved that it
solves the problem and instead it has
degenerated into this
um
wild accumulation of different
ideas that don't really fit together and
that you
uh can use to fit pretty much everything
and at this point i'm afraid i get a
little bit cynical because i've spent
too much time with theorists uh if you
give a theorist
a sufficient amount of time they will
fit you everything
right so maybe the first 10 times they
did this calculation uh they get they
got a result that was actually rude out
by observation but they they kept on
trying and eventually they found a way
to make it work i'm not saying that this
is what actually happened i i'm just
saying i've seen exactly the same thing
happening over and over and over again
you know you fumble with your with your
theory
long enough you get everything done and
of course for a philosopher's subsides
that's not a new thing uh that's exactly
what they want about
um so
you know um i'm kind of sorry for string
theories i have to say you know i i wish
it would have panned out uh but um it
doesn't seem to be going anywhere and i
mean about the g minus two i mean you
you can
er this is a long standing story you can
try to explain the discrepancy between
the standard model
prediction and the observation by adding
some kind of new particles and a lot of
people have played around with this um
the problem is that it's kind of a
rather unspecific
prediction right it could be all kinds
of particles
and they all would make some kind of
contribution that could be in about this
the right
order of magnitude
um so it doesn't really tell you all
that much
and when you wrote your first book and
you have another book coming up maybe
we'll talk about that in just a bit but
lost in math you know a lot of the
characters in it are you know very much
pro
pro strength do you have a delightful
interview with steven weinberg who sadly
passed away recently and i recommend
everybody read that wonderful book of
yours uh if nothing else to hear uh the
kind of gulliver's travels you know
sabine and wonderland uh uh travelogue
where i called it the first time that
you were on the heroine's journey this
famous archetype of joseph campbell here
with the thousand the hero takes on a
reluctant challenge and travels the
world and and then finds the magic
elixir and saves humanity and that's
kind of what you did in your first book
uh so one can only guess what the next
book will bring but in that book uh of
course yes there are a lot of commentary
on on you know kind of how math has led
physics astray as you talk about in the
subtitle et cetera the beauty is letter
district uh but i always feel like
physicists have a certain type of envy
of mathematicians in that mathematicians
have at least have girdles
incompleteness theorem so they can know
the limits of an axiomatic system which
is testable um or not or consistent or
not but physicists don't have that so we
always fall back on on falsifiability
which is just something popper came up
with and it's not necessarily written in
stone at the same level girdle his
friend girdle uh had uh girdles in
completeness theorem uh but you know
nevertheless what what else do we have
and so when i look nowadays at all these
kinds of
you know hopes for for for new projects
and where physics might be going i see a
lot of hope and experiment and a lot of
hope and observation um but even then
sometimes i i feel you um you're you're
somewhat of a critic of big projects a
big science and maybe you know these
future circular colliders obviously
you've spoken about that the lunar
collider you think is lunacy uh et
cetera et cetera but you know at some
point i was reading recently i want to
get your reaction to this um there was a
uh a claim of the tetra cork you know
the tetra quark famous tetra cork uh and
that was discovered and you know it was
some not really intended to be one of
the main goals of of of lhc or the
instruments uh that detected it but
because it had enough energy it could
make this bound state for a femtosecond
of you know four court um so let's say
we had said oh we don't need such a big
collider like that and we certainly
don't need a bigger one wouldn't we have
missed out on this and uh you know these
types of discoveries in other words what
do you say to those that say bigger is
always better and we've always learned
something we went from uh the first
cyclotron sabine here in california was
27 centimeters and now lhc is 27
kilometers it's just enormous and that's
in less than 100 years so
who's to say if we make one 30 times
bigger 40 times bigger and put on the
moon maybe we'll discover even more
things
yeah uh maybe but uh most likely not i
mean that's exactly the problem like how
do you
evaluate if it's
a reasonable risk to take because we
built this big thing on the moon there
are a lot of other things that we can't
do
and so um i i
want to try and defend myself a little
um
regarding for example um this uh tetra
quark uh story so i've certainly never
said that if we build a bigger collider
we we won't learn anything
we we would certainly learn something
more about nuclear physics
right for example those bound states and
there are all kinds of properties um of
the hadrons and
mesons and their couplings uh and the
structure of the proton itself uh and so
on that we would learn more about and we
would also almost certainly um be able
to measure more precisely the masses of
some particles that decay rates uh and
so on and so forth uh that's not nothing
um the question is is it worth uh
several dozen billion dollars
right and um it comes with the problem
that particle physicists usually try to
find some big questions you know about
the origin of the universe or dark
matter or something to sell their
machine with and
that's
where i get very uneasy because um i i
feel like i have to tell people um look
that that's
we have no reason to think that this
machine will actually see something like
this and uh
so so that's my problem um
i i actually think like this
trend of experiments to become larger
and larger
is quite pathological and
indicative of
the problems in the foundations of
physics in general
because
what's happening is basically
i mean if you look at the history of
physics for a long time what's happened
is that
um there has been some discovery
that led to some
insight some scientific insight that led
to better technology that led to better
experiments which led to new insights
which led to better technology and
better experiments and so on and so
forth and that
cycle
uh broke basically sometimes the 1970s
80s and uh since then the primary mode
uh to
get better data is just to make things
bigger and it gets more and more and
more
expensive and at some point it just
becomes an economic
problem you know does society actually
want to
invest that much money
uh
in something that might not help us all
that much at this moment in time you
know theoretically ideally we would be
able to do everything but um
you know critics and just to be pushing
back with respect to you uh as i have uh
that the you know the tokyo olympics
cost about three lhcs uh and so and when
we canceled this superconducting super
collider here in the us uh although i
claim that was actually really good for
ligo and barry barish in particular and
my friend uh my friend gary sanders
who's the new project manager for our
executive project manager and simon
observatory uh they wouldn't have won
their nobel prize if the ssc had kept
going because we know it happened when
the higgs was discovered no experimental
has won the nobel prize and we also know
that they ended up building the lhc
without needing the american money now
could have been better of course and did
we lose a generation of you know
experimental particle physicists yes um
and those are big things i'm not
trivializing that but sabine that money
didn't just go back and now now we cured
cancer thanks to canceling the super
collider in other words um i i don't i
don't think money is as fungible like
when we cut the budget we didn't get
like 80 million post docs uh from
cancelling the ssc it just went into
like now we've got like the robert bur
yeah whatever we've got some senator has
some highway named after him or her you
know it's we didn't get a return back to
physics we got it back to the budget
which you know you can estimate or you
can you know assign whatever value you
like to that but anyway um i want to ask
now about uh about another
channel which i see you doing literally
a youtube channel called sabine
haasenfelder we'll put a link to that
and it's a wonderful channel and i have
been delighted to to uh to sponsor
support your work and i will continue to
do so because i think you have a unique
mission now what you're doing and
there's a very technical term for what
you're doing science without the
gobbledygook that we learn in quantum
field theory uh where did you speaking
of quantum field theory sabine um how
did you learn to do this because when i
talk to my friends and they say oh you
got a youtube channel you're not like a
real scientist or you know like i can't
do that it's too hard it's too hard for
me and i say oh yeah i know you were
born knowing quantum field theory or you
were born knowing cryogenic engineering
at 100 millikelvin like yeah we you just
were born knowing that like you didn't
have to work at that of course they did
how did you come to be um you know so
proficient to grow in less than a year
factor of eight to ten followers now a
third of a million people are addicted
to your videos every saturday morning
sabine did you study it did you work on
it how did you come to be this at this
level of of youtube uh uh of of youtube
success
an outreach success not just i mean the
the brief answer is i don't know
i mean
you know i'm super excited people uh
like my channel um
but it's not that i have a big secret or
something i just talk about what i think
uh is interesting and uh so i hope that
people uh notice that uh i i personally
look into it and uh i i try to
communicate what i've learned and so
they the audience is kind of part of the
story right i look at what uh comments
they leave what they are interested in
and i have a list to take notes
um and try to address questions
um
but
i mean i think i've just done the
obvious right i mean you i go on the
internet and i look at advice that other
people had
um and
i've tried to follow it to the extent
that i could um that they're always just
limitations like i for example i think
it might my channel would be much much
more interesting if i wouldn't just
stand in front of a green screen all the
time
uh but
i have no one to do my camera work uh
for me uh it i'm just one person uh and
that's as much as i can do so you know
i'm trying to work with what i have um
and uh
basically i'm just learning by doing
right i try to look at what works uh
what does not work
and i also i mean there's always you
must know this yourself i mean um
the the youtube algorithm isn't always
that easy
to swallow you know
so there are a lot of things for example
videos that i cared a lot about that
just sank to the bottom of the sea and
you know i'm trying to not take it
personally and not try to get
discouraged and i stick to what matters
to me uh but but on a on a very
uh you know pragmatic basis there are
limits to what you can do like and now i
have to pay to other people so i have to
think a little bit about uh
what works and what doesn't work uh and
so there are trade-offs to be made but
in the end i feel like you know if if i
i don't enjoy it if it doesn't make
sense to me um then i wouldn't continue
to do it so
i try to listen to myself to some extent
and it's very successful and of course
you need to learn a lot of soft skills
that aren't any relationship to your day
job as a theoretical physicist and those
include you know promotions
advertisements click-through rates
thumbnails uh are you completely
self-taught in those regimes as well or
are there tips you can give to aspiring
youtube stars like me
i i really don't have any secrets you
know i just google the stuff and then i
look at what what other people recommend
uh and uh i try to follow this as good
as i can i look at the statistics
though honestly i'm trying not to
overthink it because uh as i just said
sometimes it just doesn't make sense you
look at it and you're like why
is this video not work right
and and sometimes i feel like it was
just something stupid like maybe there
was just a big headline and no one was
interested in watching this particular
thing at this particular time and then
the way that youtube goes if the video
doesn't really take off in the first one
two days you can forget about it
basically
that's the end of the story gets lost in
uh and hassenfelder evaporation instead
of hockey
um let's get back to some physics uh
what do you think nowadays is sort of uh
drawing you know most of your attention
whether it's positive attention negative
attention is it things you've written
about determinism super determinism i
want to get into your paper from last
year about that uh before we end up but
um free will simulation hypothesis ai
apocalypse fifth forces what do you
think is like getting most of your
attention or and what do you think
deserves even more attention
than it's getting well um so i i'm
afraid i'm i'm terribly boring in that i
actually try to listen to my own advice
um and if you remember i mean the way my
book came about was that i was trying to
decide what's a promising research topic
and
so uh maybe i thought about it too much
that i ended up writing this book and
interviewing all these people but in the
end i came to a conclusion and um
i can honestly say this was not a
conclusion that i had uh when i wrote
the proposal or when i sent out
writing the book
which uh was that we have to pay more
attention to inconsistencies and by this
i mean both inconsistencies between
observations and theory that's kind of
the obvious inconsistency that everyone
is thinking about but also internal
inconsistencies uh in the theories
whereas a lot of the problems that uh
theoretical physicists and foundations
presently look at are not problems of
inconsistency they are
aesthetic misgivings that's the way that
i put it in the book
um
and um
i mean there's there's an obvious big
inconsistency between um the predictions
of general relativity and the standard
model and our observations which is dark
matter
so um i basically switched to working on
dark matter because at least in this
area we have observations right we have
plenty of observations
and um i'm i'm trying not to do the same
thing that everybody else has been doing
you know with inventing new particles uh
and just trying to guess something uh
i'm going at it at least i'm trying to
you know going at it more
um from
the
more general side you know what's the
kind of theory that we would need uh to
resolve this um discrepancy and and i
arrived at the conclusion that we need
something that's kind of a hybrid
uh between dark matter and modified
gravity and this is why i'm working on
this super fluid superfloating
yeah you had um you had a wonderful
video a couple months ago that was maybe
a million views it's called dark matter
the situation has changed in which you
advocate for kind of a um you know a
cometus or you know kind of a synthesis
between methods of condensed matter
physics with methods of traditional you
know particle instantiations for
solutions to dark matter um so is has
the situation changed further since that
video uh came out are you more kind of
excited about super maybe you could say
a little bit about superfluidity i find
that so fascinating talk about this idea
how it came up and and what the
implications could be uh because super
fluidity just to take a step back as an
experimentalist fascinating subject uh
related to uh you know superfluid
superconductivity same mathematics et
cetera uh in a lot of ways as they bulk
properties of correlated phenomena in
solid state systems or condensed matter
systems what does that have to do with
the cosmos as a whole i mean the cosmos
is at three kelvin it's not a you know
now how does super fluidity come into
play
uh
yeah what does it have to do with the
cosmos that's exactly the that's exactly
the problem right um so um
you see the the issue with um
dark matter is and we've known this for
a long time that it works better in some
regimes than in others and then we have
this alternative explanation which is
modified gravity um that
also works better in some places than in
others and these are kind of
complementary to each other and what's
been going on for a long time is that
each side of the argument said no this
is right um
oh no this is right and you are wrong
and so it's been going back and forth
and it didn't really lead to anything
and so i think the the obvious answer
the answer i dare to say uh is uh where
you need them both you need dark matter
in the regimes where dark matter works
uh which is like cluster scale cmb that
kind of stuff and you need modified
gravity uh mostly on the scale of
galaxies because where you have these
flat rotation uh curves and tully
fischer law and and uh all that kind of
stuff and this
is not originally my idea that you can
do it with a superfluid but it's
something that i learned from justin
curry who i'm sure you you also know
and uh you know i remember reading this
paper and at this time i was working on
super fluids but for an entirely
different reason you know i just read
this because i thought maybe it will
give me some inspiration you know it's
close enough that i would probably
understand some of it
and i just thought this makes so much
sense
right so you can put it both together
and you can have the best of either side
and not worry about the worst of both
sides uh then of course you know if you
start looking a little bit more in the
details it's not quite as simple
right
and um
the biggest problem that i face is that
um this is really condensed metaphorics
which is something that i wasn't trained
in and uh what you do
sorry i've been talking too much uh what
do you do with a super fluid in a curved
spacetime
i really don't know and um
most of the people who work on it now or
pretty much everybody i guess
they they come from the general
relativity astrophysics cosmology side
or from the particle physics side and
and then none of them is really a
condensed meta physicist who might have
some intuition as to what is going on or
could actually you know look at it and
say look this is a problem you need to
fix this or actually uh you know i've
been playing with this kind of theory
for a long time and this assumption
doesn't work with this um or there's
there's an example that you could use
where uh which is this and so we so we
don't have this so we're kind of
you know um
poking in the dark uh trying to figure
out a way to make it work
um but
there has to be a way to go about it
more systematically so
you said you you saw my video about it
it was kind of a call like you know
really to condensed uh meta people to
say look there's an opportunity uh we we
we need some kind of meta people to
figure out what to do with those
superfluids in galaxies uh which sounds
really weird but um
yeah so i i realized i forgot to explain
how the whole idea works to begin with
so
so the so the idea is that um
you have this stuff that kind of behaves
the same like normal dark matter called
dark matter um just the particles are
light but basically that's it
on the large scales and between
the galaxies and so on
but in the galaxies where you have
fairly um deep gravitational potentials
i mean deep compared to the rest um
this stuff can condense into the super
fluid phase where it can um
it has a quantum coherent
um effects uh spent through the whole
galaxy which is like really
mind-boggling
you know like correlated like cooper
pairs that span the you know but but uh
solitons or whatever that span the
correlation length of the galaxy
yeah so so we don't deal with cooper
pass um actually but um yeah in
principle yes
yeah yeah yeah so we just we just use
scale of fields you know there's a
simple thing that you can do
as a theorist it's just a scatter field
um and that might that might actually be
the problem with it here so maybe maybe
scared of it it's just too simple um
and um in in the superfluid um the
phonons so the excitations over the
fluid they they generate uh an
additional force and it's this new force
that adds on top of the gravitational
pull and makes it look like a
modification of gravity so it turns out
that this additional force it it has
pretty much the same behavior as gravity
already so which is why it just adds on
top
and
so this is really neat so you have
natural the idea to say you know if i'm
allowed to use the word uh you have
these two regimes of the equations that
it explains why sometimes the code dark
matter stuff works better and why
sometimes the modified gravity stuff uh
works better but you know the devil's in
the details right i mean yeah
for example one completely unsolved
problem is like what do you do with the
solar system
yes exactly
always some kind of magic yeah
it'll work out somehow we just don't
know basically yeah
the only place we know that superfluids
exist for sure in the solar system
uh that's uh yeah very fascinating i'll
put links to that in the in the show
notes as well that wonderful video you
mentioned justin curry who's a friend
and i've known for a long time uh in
especially in the context of what was
called originally the ek pyrotic
universe which he worked on with his
advisor paul steinhardt and neil turock
and others and now he seems to not be as
intimately correlated with those uh
folks and now we have uh uh anna aegis
uh who's a uh who's a scientist actually
i think she's in germany now uh as well
and she's working with paul steinhardt
and they have come up with with what's
known as bouncing cosmology and it
is not connected to this colliding
membranes and so forth and it makes a
testable prediction that we shall not
see any b modes unfortunately of
primordial character in uh my simon's
observatory or my former colleagues on
the bicep team
we will not see primarily modes because
they don't exist because inflation
didn't take place
and i wonder what kinds of reactions you
have to that to theories that are
becoming more and more frequent there
are theories of sir roger penrose which
also you know he played big role in in
pointing out issues with inflation
obviously uh in the early days uh and
paul obviously was responsible for new
inflation and solving a lot of the
problems that lin uh linday uh and
others took on what do you make of this
uh uh of this you know flourishing of
alternatives uh not asking you to say is
it right is it wrong or you know can you
but they have the virtue both uh roger's
theory which i don't even i pointed out
to him sabina last week on his birthday
uh that uh his theory is unique in that
it's the only new cosmology that you
know cyclical but also uh doesn't have a
scalar field and makes a falsifiable
prediction in other words um the uh
curry and and steinhardt and anna aegis
their theory predicts a uh or at least
anaegis and paul steinhardt's does
predicts a that there should be no
primordial bemoans as i said but also
needs a scalar field
but roger doesn't need a scalar field in
his theory he needs his wild curvature
but whatever there's no scalar field i
think that's the most virtuous thing
right because if you're trying to kill
off inflation which has a scalar field
you'd like to not have to have a new
theory that has a scalar field how do
you react to conformal cichlid cosmology
and bouncing cosmology
so what's with his aerobonds
his uh his his error bonds
oh for dark matter yeah that's his
solution for dark matter yeah um i think
you can have conformal cyclic cosmology
with without error bonds the error bonds
are sort of uh
his his uh his kind of formulation to
explain the dark matter problem but i
think you can have it with just hawking
uh points and so forth you can have it
with just these eons which doesn't um
you know which which that doesn't make
use of a scalar field error bonds are
more like particle instantiations than
scalar fields i think
well
okay so i mean i'm not deeply familiar
with this so i'll just take it uh as you
say it
um so
this brings us back again to this
question like what's with the philosophy
and um by the way all these different
theories for the early universe is one
of the topics i go on about in my book
like how did the universe begin
and
i think that led to problems with with
what what people are doing
one is that
too many people in um theoretical
physics and the foundations um tend to
think if a theory makes predictions if
it's falsifiable that means it's a good
scientific theory right astrology makes
falsifiable predictions right is it good
science well uh yeah uh right exactly
that's the problem right i mean uh
tomorrow uh i don't know you will win
the lottery that's totally a falsifiable
prediction uh we don't call it
scientific and so i i really think a lot
of people have to think much deeper
about um why your theory is scientific
and a big problem i have with all these
tales for the early universe is that
they make a lot of assumptions
um which you actually don't need
to get the predictions uh and this is
also why you have this huge degeneracy
uh among models that pretty much make
the same predictions right i mean
there's some order you say well we see
the bmo's and then the others who say we
we don't see them but you know we will
see
if we see them or don't see them and
then we will have a number
uh and that will not allow you to tell
which of the theories was right why
because they just have way too many
details that don't reflect uh in the
actual predictions
and um
i mean this is already the case for um
you know in inflation um
it it's you basically
whatever data
you throw at inflation you can fiddle it
around somehow uh to make it work and so
i'm pretty sure you know um if you don't
see the if you do see the b modes and
that runs into conflict uh with what
whatever model it is that uh curry is
currently working with you can probably
fix it somehow by making it a little bit
more complicated uh you know the same
problem that i was already talking about
earlier
[Music]
and it's i mean it's a difficult
question like is this something that's
specific to the origin of our universe
that
will forever prevent us from really
figuring out what went on
and i suspect that as long as we stay
with
the current type of theories that we use
which require an initial condition
we will never be able to
to really solve the problem because
there will always remain this problem
like why this initial condition right
uh and and and the other problem is also
that if you have a model like
you have a balance or something um
generically what happens is that you
have an intermediate phase you know
which is
close by what we think of as the big
bang
um where everything was simple
but actually earlier in in this previous
um phase it could have been much more
difficult
more complicated what it should have
been the word um and
that's the problem because our entire
scientific methodology is based on
making things simpler so if the universe
came from something that was more
complicated even if that was right
our scientific methodology
wouldn't allow us to actually figure out
if that was really the case
i look at some of the virtues of it and
by the way i think it's it's healthy to
have other approaches rather than just a
monolithic monopoly that inflation and
even the standard model have become uh
in particle physics um but uh i wonder
what do you make of the fundamental
objection i think sir roger pointed out
first uh was this you know extremely
unlikely you know low entropy condition
in the early universe uh that uh you
know had to be instantiated either via
what albert i think calls the past
hypothesis or uh and some other
instantiation uh versus having some
mechanism to establish that so in in
steinhardt aegis they have very small
contractions very large expansions and
those do cycle over eternity but they
avoid the entropy um runaway problem of
tolman universes etc but uh but in sir
rogers is manifestly because the
universe dilutes and all that's left are
photons and uh and the entropy at each
eon can be quite low do you think this
is a big problem the problem of entropy
and i want to connect that uh you know
the the low entropy starting point so
that we could have an error of time or
do you think that's another example of
hype
well
i i wouldn't say it's a problem in that
it's not an inconsistency right as i
said earlier i think people should focus
on inconsistencies just
because that's historically where
progress has come from but you can
certainly ask um like is there an easier
explanation
um so so maybe to to give people uh some
context uh no one really knows why the
universe started
in
a state of very low entropy you just
have to postulate it uh without that
assumption the theories just don't work
for some unknown reason it wasn't low
entropy
but why so penrose's theory um is a way
to explain it um and that's i think what
was his motivation um to
connect the fighter say to the end state
and uh basically erase all this entropy
um
but you have to ask like isn't the cure
worse than the disease like is it
actually simpler
to do other stuff with the wild
curvature hypothesis and error bonds and
then going down to the
isn't it easier to just say okay it
started at low entropy
and so um i would say
given the observations that we currently
have
um the past hypothesis is the simplest
we can do therefore
it's currently just the best theory that
that we have of course that may not
remain so and then penrose of course
knows this perfectly well which is
exactly why he's looking for other
evidence like uh he used to be looking
for circles on the cmb and now he's
looking for his his talking points
and i mean in principle that's good but
i mean
you know how it goes i mean if you have
sufficiently many people analyzing data
and sufficiently many ways
eventually they would find something
so
you know i'm not saying it's wrong but
uh there are many things you can do with
um
trying different methods of analysis
the last thing i want to finish up with
is relates to a conversation you had
with luke barnes
and justin bierly unbelievable a few
months back and that has to do with
fine-tuning et cetera and there's this
resurgence of interest uh in the uh in
the claim that uh producing entropy or
low entropy states require a mind you
know organization codes et cetera those
are all always traceable in our
experience to an intellect a mind now
obviously what they want to do is
correlate that to a god right which i
know you don't affirm a belief in i
think if you had evidence maybe i don't
i don't want to get into that but but i
want to get into is this a problem in
other words is the you know the instant
like when lawrence krauss talked about a
universe from nothing it's not really
nothing because there's a hilbert space
and maybe the cure is worse than the
diseases you say uh you know there's
there's a you need a hilbert space and
you need certain mathematical operations
you need quantum physics um you need the
wheeler dewitt equation you need the
board booth for
criteria anyway all these things uh seem
to suggest that there was since there
was a low entropy state uh the universe
is somehow finely tuned uh and then
obviously the genetic code of dna is
another example that's often used as an
example of something that is highly
organized and ordered and uh not
flawless but but that perhaps is uh you
know provides evidence for
in these intelligent design people's
minds for a creator what do you say to
such people is is fine-tuning an issue
you and i talked by twitter dm which is
the most efficient form of communication
about a paper by fred adams you know
saying no the universe isn't very finely
tuned at all at least if you just look
at star formation which is but one
ingredient so what do you make of fine
tuning is it a problem is it not a
problem and first of all what is it what
do you think of when i say fine tuning
what does it mean to you
yeah so i'm a little bit confused
because normally the fine-tuning
arguments that people talk about in
cosmology and also what i talked about
with bonds
are not about
the
entropy being small but they're talking
about uh small variations in the
constants of nature
that
would just you know ruin one or the
other process that we believe
has given rise to life on earth like for
example stars wouldn't shine or galaxies
wouldn't form uh that kind of thing
um and and so that's what they're
usually talking about um
is is that a problem um i would say no
and actually i go on about this in my in
my book right um because
um i don't know what it means
for a small change
for for change to be small to the
constants of nature i mean after all
their constants because they're
constants you can't change them so why
would i worry about it
so to me this is really a metaphysical
problem
again i would say it's just
not scientific um people are worried
about um some property of the theory um
that has just no relevance for
observations
so which is why you know it's it's not
that i
try to prescribe people what they should
spend their time on
but personally i think
nothing will come out of it because
there's no inconsistency that needs to
be resolved and people are just worrying
over nothing
and uh
i i definitely appreciate that now
another you know kind of criticism that
i hear often is uh alternative theories
you know when you talk to a string
theory i talked to kaku and he was like
well loop quantum gravity uh can't even
incorporate fermions and uh and he kind
of went off on that and then you know
lee smolin seemed to kind of not i
wouldn't say agree but he he did seem to
be less i don't know if you've detected
a little bit less sanguine about about
loop quantum gravity lately in other
words uh
he he sort of has uh maybe realized that
things like variable speed constants
very speedy light varying alpha
those are not really being borne out in
any data and those were sort of
predictions and delayed arrival time for
high frequency versus low frequency
photons you know seems to be ruled out i
had carlo revellion twice this year and
he's still very positive about it what
do you make of alternatives uh to these
uh to these you know kind of theories of
everything or at least uh quantum
gravity
well for one
i suspect there would be a lot of people
who work on a loop quantum gravity who
would object that those were actually
predictions uh you know it's
as you probably know it's very hard to
actually calculate something
straight from the foundation of the
theory you know it's very heavy
mathematically you basically it's a very
similar problem to string theory by the
way
um so if you just take the fundamentals
of the theory you can't calculate
anything from it and and so what people
do is they uh they build some kind of
effective model
uh and they're different ways that you
can do it and people have done it
different ways and uh that way you can
arrive at predictions but then your
predictions depend on those additional
assumptions
right and and so um
you can in the end you will always only
rule out those models um but not
necessarily this underlying structure um
that's not a specific problem that's
specific to loop quantum gravity um
so
i i'm not sure that i fully understand
the question
so you're asking do i have any opinions
on uh different approaches to quantum
gravity yeah i guess my conju my
conjecture is that uh we are putting the
toe
before the gut in other words we're all
fixated on a theory of of quantum
gravity but we don't even have a grand
unified theory that everyone agrees with
unless i'm wrong and please correct me
if i'm wrong but so people are kind of
skipping the line and and
you know it's kind of hard to think
about oh let's discover the yang mills
equations before we discover maxwell's
equations well yeah so
is this another example of of something
that's misguided or is it a sign of a
healthy field that's looking for a
thousand flowers to bloom
well i would say it's actually good
because uh the that we're missing a
theory of quantum gravity that's an
actual inconsistency
um whereas um there's nothing
inconsistent uh about the three system
the standard model not being unified i
mean you can say well it's kind of ugly
but i would argue well that's not a
scientific argument
and so i think it's actually more
worthwhile um to try to solve the
inconsistency between general relativity
and
quantum field theory now of course the
question is like
which one is the right approach and
so
it's also something i go on about in my
book
mathematical consistency alone uh is not
sufficient you always need experimental
guidance in the end
and
this is why
you know i i'm always
dismayed let me put it this way if if
theoreticians who spend a lot of time on
loop quantum gravity or string theory or
something else don't seem to show any
interest in what you can actually
experimentally do in the laboratory
and ironically enough
that problem
in you know if i may extrapolate the
next 20 years or something seems to be
so from the side of the experimentalists
who just don't care that the
theoreticians don't get their act
together
and they're well on the way on actually
testing
mind boggling as this still sounds to me
uh the weak field limit of uh quantum
gravity you know that they're actually
experimentally uh experimental groups
are pushing um
towards this and i think this is super
super exciting and i really wish that
the theorists you know the strength
theorists and quantum gravity people and
what have you would actually make a
prediction for an experiment before they
make the experiment not the retro
addiction right yeah exactly people like
well einstein did it with the perihelion
of mercury i'm like but he also had a
few predictions and it wasn't just a
retroaddiction i want to close sabine
because i've been told that you're
working on another book which i can't
wait i hope that you'll come back onto
the into the impossible podcast when
that's out so we can sell millions of
copies of that book on the show
but can you talk about this issue that
you wrote about last october called
super determinism um how does it relate
to free will uh is this all an illusion
because i find that with your
predilection for looking for
inconsistencies i find this like almost
hopeless because you know according to
some people everything has consciousness
the electron and you know and you can
talk about free will as participatory or
not but anyway what is this super
determinism what is this this wonderful
paper and and how does it feature maybe
perhaps a preview of your upcoming book
okay that that was a wild question brian
i know there was actually five good
questions
but you can handle it so my my book
doesn't actually have anything to do
with super determinism on freight
or freeway yeah i do go on a little bit
about uh free will but free will has
nothing to do with super determinism
so maybe let me start with this um
so
i think people get a little bit confused
about the word super determinism because
it has this phrase to determinism
um right so so
how can something
something possibly be more deterministic
than deterministic
to which the answer is well it can't
really so super deterministic theory is
just deterministic in the
normal boring sense
and determinism
has always been a problem for people who
believe in free will and there's like a
2 000 year old history to this and uh
super determinism doesn't really change
anything about it you know if you were
fine with talking about free will in the
context of determinism you should still
be fine with it in the context of super
determinism
super determinism really refers to
a peculiar assumption in bell's theorem
that's called statistical independence
and
the statistical independence assumption
says that if you have a theory in which
the measurement outcome is determined by
hidden variables so that's the kind of
thing that einstein believed in
um
then
the outcome of the measurement is
correlated with the detector settings
and a lot of people have taken this to
mean that the
the experimentalist is kind of prevented
from drilling the knob for whatever way
they please
and i look at it in exactly the opposite
way um you can twiddle the knob whatever
way you please but you affect the time
evolution of the state that you're
trying to measure so you know in my mind
it's it's far more innocent than what
people um try to interpret into this
equation i actually have a paper coming
out like next week
about the interpretation of the
statistical independence assumption that
explains another problem with this
common interpretation oh wow and but you
call it hopeless
personally i think that's the most
promising thing to work on which is why
i work on it of course
um because um the the measurement
problem has been such a long-standing
issue
and uh after working on quantum gravity
for a long time i've pretty much come to
the conclusion that the reason we're not
solving the problem with quantum gravity
is that we don't understand quantum
theory in the first place
and we have this update of the wave
function as you certainly know which
kind of happens instantaneously
everywhere
and
general relativity can't cope with it
it'll it'll never work so we have to get
rid of this instantaneous measurement
update
and find a theory that respects the
symmetry
of general relativity from the bottom up
and super determinism can do it for you
so you you have a theory like quantum
theory that violates what bell called
local causality you can make it locally
causal on the expense of violating
statistical independence and so that
that's why i'm excited about it
okay great and so uh can you tell us a
little bit about a tease a little bit
about the book that's coming out in 2022
yes um so the book's called more than
this
um and it's
about what physics says about the big
questions of our existence that's the
beginning of the universe we briefly
touched on this but also
uh free will or questions like does the
universe think does the past still exist
um
and um are electrons conscious you know
what what you just uh brought up can we
create a universe um is human behavior
predictable
that that was the worst chapter it
caused me a big headache um so every
chapter is a question and and then i
have uh answers to it and broken down
into more specific questions basically
well it sounds like a beautiful book
which is ironic compared to your
subtitle of your last book uh sabina
hassenfelder proprietress of the sabine
hossenfelder
podcast or sabine hussenfelder youtube
channel science without the gobbledygook
you can find that everywhere that fine
science videos are sold and bought proud
to be a sponsor i will never cancel you
we love you so much here in the states
and around the world and i want to thank
you for spending so much of your time
with us today
well thank you for having me good to
talk to you
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode with the
irascible irrepressible sabina
hassenfelder i know you'll like my
previous interview with her
and make sure to subscribe leave a
comment and what you found to be most
free of gobbledygook and irascibility
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]